right now I think it's enormously
difficult because there are so many
people who are out there making stuff
which is great but there isn't really a
venue
besides you know it's watching TV in the
afternoon and I'm bored and I want to
try something new and the biggest part
of that is trying something new right
now that is not a huge part of our
culture certainly not our film culture
right now most of it is find a brand
name and you know that people already
know and go with that and obviously
other people have been just as
curmudgeonly as me about this and I
admit guilty of it as anyone I've been
in doing my superhero movies etc but
we've got to a state where the studios
are pretty relentless about just trying
to have an inn before they even start a
project that's not the case with all
films but it is with a ton of them and
obviously most of the big-budget ones
part of the problem is that there's a
dialogue going on between audiences and
studios that is devolving and because
they keep finding a lower common
denominator and this doesn't mean that
the films are bad it just means that the
ways in which they're approaching what
they're gonna make have become kind of
ossified but at the same time audiences
are more likely to turn out for
something that they already know and
they already like that's why you know
obviously the biggest movie of the last
few years
Jem and the Holograms was you know just
swept the nature well okay it swept my
daughter so I thought it was big um but
doesn't always work but the problem is
that there there isn't really a
willingness by a lot of people to go
into something that they don't already
know now none of this helps you by the
way sorry and you flew all this way but
I do think that it's something that
needs to be addressed that you used to
go to the movies and have no idea
what you were gonna see I am actually
old enough to have done that to have
gone to the local theatre because
something was playing my parents would
just send me by myself and I could be
rated R it could be whatever didn't
matter was just like just get rid of him
and and you know there were very weird
conglomeration of seventies movies and
and but we you just didn't know that was
the contract I'll go see the movie I
want to I want to I'll open the box I
want to see what's inside
people don't do that anymore and we keep
making it harder to I have trouble
watching movies after I've seen a
trailer because I've seen the movie
they've given me every beat it's
terrible
but unfortunately changing it means that
people have to we have to find a
platform that people will come to with
that contract with that contract of I
don't know yet this is a new person this
is untested I don't know what the plot
of this is I don't know where this
stands you know as long as they're not
gonna be you know suddenly heads being
chopped off or something just egregious
like actual childbirth much much worse
than violence on film
you know French movies they'll do
anything but as long as you know there's
some parameters people do need to sort
of embrace the mystery of what a
narrative can be so that we start you
know shaking up when a narrative could
be and they're not all hero origin
stories now if they're all hero origin
stories about adolescent girls with
superpowers and [ __ ] all y'all that's
just what I like okay that that's okay
but but yeah it's it's it's not
something that exists it's something
that I've been thinking about a lot
because I get questions like this and I
wish I want to be more helpful I'd feel
like there's a venue whether it's on the
internet whether it's you know where you
know if we could get people to subscribe
to something that they go in going
surprise me then we will have more
opportunities like that and people will
be
to be heard who haven't yet that's
something that I would love to create
but I don't know if anybody would show
up to that party I like this outfit this
is maybe my favorite outfit um you have
confirmed that you're going to be doing
dr. horrible - are you yeah but I've
done that like a lot of tats right here
but it's like I'm like Patton Oswalt say
he needs to lose weight it's like every
routine he does a bit about that you
know it's like I'm definitely gonna get
on it any minute now are you yet going
to release any ideas that you really
have surrounding it is it going to be
more like a prequel like the comic or is
it going to be a continuation of the
first film are we going to potentially
get to see how Billy picked himself back
up after the tragedy at the end of the
first film well let me lay out exactly
what's gonna happen for you and then I'd
like to see you a couple of the numbers
that we've written I all I can think is
me saying that it's a prequel just so
the actors can just freak out and run to
the gym oh [ __ ]
prequel you son of a [ __ ] otherwise
just kick it wet hot American summer
style and don't care but but no it is
not it is it takes place after the
events it takes place at a time when dr.
Horrible's is you know sort of the king
of the world he's he's made it he's made
it big and so everything's going to go
really well it's about three minutes
long and sings about that he's happy and
there are birds and that's it that's all
you get
but no it's not a pretty cool Nathan go
back to bed I wanted to say I think I
speak for a lot of people when I say
we'd love to see you back on Twitter
but if if you could comment on leaving
and how audiences have changed since
Buffy started in 97 well you know
everybody in the world
has the ear of everybody who wants to
listen and as we know that's a
double-edged sword
certainly Buffy was the first show
probably one of the first shows where
there was an open dialogue between the
creators and the audience during the run
of the show that would on occasion
affect how things happened in the show
and but then that you know sort of a
little bit has devolved into [ __ ] you do
it my way and and that gets ahold pretty
fast I think a lot of discourse right
now is developing and I think that
unfortunately venues like Twitter have a
lot to do with that when you only have
enough characters to say [ __ ] you do it
my way you know people aren't let again
setting up reasoned arguments people
aren't paying attention for as long
they're just sort of saying they're bit
it could be something lovely it could be
something funny it could be you know
hang yourself here's the news when we
when can I kill you stuff like that less
fun less interesting but eventually it
becomes a kind of white noise and then
you just sort of you can't remember what
the dialogue was and you sort of stop
having it I didn't leave Twitter because
people were being mean to me although it
was nice when it stopped I left Twitter
because I was fascinated by so much that
I just sort of got a little addicted to
it and I was like oh I have to read
about this I ever read about that like
this and I just I was heard all these
voices all the time and I had to step
away so that I could hear my own and
after quitting Twitter is when I started
to be able to write again which took a
while Ultron was you know a big
endeavour kind of made me sleepy after
so so I had to you know I had to shut
out that noise I would like always to be
able to have a dialogue with the
audience but at the same time
um you know you can't create by
committee you have to do things that
come from your increasing gut and then
that's just sort of it hey there are
there's parameters it's it's important
to understand the audience and to
embrace them but it's also important to
know when it's your turn to talk
you